كادن بونتوري هو خريج
مدرسة ثانوية برينستون عندما تخرج في عام
2022 أدرك أن الكلية لم تكن بالنسبة
له ذهب إلى مركز التوظيف بالقوات المسلحة
لكنه كان يزن
365 رطلاً ، ولن يأخذ
الجيش الجنود الذين يعانون من السمنة المفرطة ولكن
المجند  جلس الرقيب مايكل
كيثلي مع بونتوري
ووضعه في طريق لفقدان الوزن ، لذا فإن
الكثير مما نقوم به هنا هو التدريب
والتوجيه خاصة مع هؤلاء الشباب
والشابات الذين يتطلعون للانضمام
إلى الخدمة العسكرية  لقد
كان معنا يعدل خطط نظامه الغذائي
لمساعدته على التوصل إلى خطط تمرين جديدة
تعرفها عندما وصل إلى مرحلة الاستقرار
ويمنعه من الاستسلام وأشياء من هذا القبيل
استيقظت كل يوم وذهبت إلى صالة الألعاب الرياضية التي عملت
بها لمدة ساعة تقريبًا و  نصف ساعتين
كل يوم الكثير من الكارديو
والالتزام بها في خطة نظامي الغذائي فقط
أتناول الكثير من خضروات الدجاج المشوي
وحاول فقط عدم تناول الوجبات السريعة
والبقاء بصحة جيدة وشرب الكثير من
الماء
خسر بونتوري
145 رطلاً الآن وهو يتمتع باللياقة البدنية والكثير من التشذيب
بوزن 220 رطلاً ، هذا هو أول
يوم كامل له كجندي مجند في الجيش
مع مسار مهني عسكري ليصبح
متخصصًا في عمليات الطيران ، أعني أن
هذه الرحلة ليست مستحيلة
هنا دليل على ذلك  إلى أي شخص
آخر يبحث أو يفكر في ذلك ،
أنا أكثر من اللازم أو لدي الكثير من
المشكلات الطبية أو أن الجيش لن يقبلني ،
فأنت لا تعرف ما لم تحاول ذلك ، أعني أنني
على استعداد لمساعدة أي شخص
يريد ذلك حقًا  كونوا هنا يظهرون أن
التفاني نفسه الذي أظهره هذا
الشاب سيساعدهم
طوال رحلتهم بالإضافة إلى البقاء
متحمسًا وسيأتي وقتك
بعد ذلك
فقط وتأكد فقط من وجود
مجموعة الأصدقاء المناسبة حولك  للتأكد من أنك
على دراية بكل ما ستنشره كايدن في
المعسكر التدريبي في سبتمبر هنا من أجلك في
برينستون ، أنا روبرت كاستيلو دبليو فيفا نيوز